Here are this week's top movies.
Your king will come. It is inevitable.
In King Arthur: Legend of the Sword, director Guy Ritchie gives us his rowdy take on the mythical tale.
Behold! Your born king!
Against the backdrop of East LA car culture, a street artist hopes to make his dreams come true in Lowriders
That is your heritage!
You're on vacation here with your boyfriend?
No, I'm just just here with, um,
my mom.
When a woman vacations with her scaredy-cat mom in Snatched, kidnapping and hilarity ensue.
See what's hot in theaters with this week's Fanticipation.
So what' s your weekend ticket going to be?
Let us know by commenting.
See you next time on Weekend Ticket.